o wocs alguns anos eu decidi que eu ia
ficar uma semana inteira dentro de um
presídio feminino
eu trabalhava como jornalista para uma
revista e eu soube que iria acontecer um
concurso de miss presidiária e como eu
estava interessada nessa relação entre
mulheres presas e beleza eu achei que
seria a melhor coisa que eu queria pra
fazer
e naquela ocasião eu encontrei uma moça
de 19 anos que se chamava paula natália
a paula tinha sido condenada por
seqüestro
na verdade ela era namorada de um membro
do pcc que tinha sequestrado o
empresário ali a polícia chegou pra a
desmantelar o cativeiro ela estava lá e
foi presa em flagrante
e aí eu comecei a conversar com a paula
e reparei que ela tinha uma tatuagem na
nuca com aquele símbolo da reciclagem e
aquilo me intrigou eu perguntei pra ela
paula que tenha fato agem aí no pescoço
e aí ela virou pra mim e falou assim
sabe que é sandra é que quando eu morrer
e foi até o instituto médico legal e meu
corpo estiver lá esticado na maca o
pessoal vai olhar e vai falar poxa não é
tudo lixo da praia reaproveitada para
reciclar
quem sabe eu venho melhor na próxima
vida
uau é difícil ter a gente imaginar o
nosso corpo morto assim com tanta
facilidade não há palavra fácil e eu
perguntei para ela também
mas poxa paula por que você entrou aí no
mundo do crime por que você não foi
trabalhar numa empresa vendeu umas
coisas abrir um negócio e aí ela olhou
pra mim mais espantada ainda com o olho
deste tamanho e falou pra mim
sandra mas que que é isso empresa
carreira isso é coisa de homem
não é coisa de menina não tá maluca
naquele momento eu percebi que a paula
natália não tinha modelos na cabeça dela
só existiam as atrizes e as celebridades
que o aviã nas revistas e na tv e como
ela não podia ser nenhuma delas
ela optou pelo mundo do crime e não pelo
mundo dos negócios
faltam modelos para paula natália pra
outras palavras natalinas
as meninas hoje no brasil eu não sei se
vocês já repararam mas quando nós
entramos nos sites de revistas ou os
sites de informação em geral
nós encontramos lá política economia aí
você vai rolando descendo na página até
encontrar esportes e lá pra baixo
encontra a vinheta mulher lá embaixo da
vinheta mulher existem os assuntos de
mulher que são moda beleza decoração
horóscopo
olha não tem nada contra isso não
aliás é um caso foi o meu batom vermelho
e eu gosto muito de ser feminina
eu até dou uma espiadinha no meu
horóscopo também no meu signo você sair
de casa mas o que eu não posso entender
é que neste ano de 2015 ainda seja
necessário separar o assunto mulher do
cenário político e econômico
eu guardei aquela história dentro de mim
e hoje eu trabalho com jornalismo de
negócios e eu posso dizer para vocês
esqueçam que eu não vejo o menor sentido
em existir em revistas de negócios de um
lado e revistas femininas do outro lado
sabe que porque as mulheres estão
fazendo negócios
elas estão num mundo dos negócios
mas o que aparece por aí o que a
sociedade mostra são as mulheres-fruta
né
as mulheres sexies
a miss bumbum ou então as marias
chuteiras
dessa forma fica muito difícil para o
nosso imaginário concebê a ideia de uma
mulher talentosa e competente o que a
sociedade nos oferece
são três papéis que são confortáveis que
a maioria das pessoas pensarem nas
mulheres desse jeito não relação
prostitutas ou elas são mães ou elas são
bruxas não se pensa uma mulher no mundo
dos negócios
falta visibilidade e representatividade
as mulheres hoje que estão trabalhando
construindo nosso país são invisíveis
mas as mulheres não são mais um nicho de
mercado
as mulheres são o mercado e elas estão
construindo empresas elas estão fundando
suas próprias empresas
elas estão dentro do mundo profissional
e por que será que essas mulheres nunca
aparece
ela tem ainda muita dificuldade de
chegar a cargos de liderança
hoje nós temos cerca de 33 milhões de
mulheres em registros ele te no brasil
mas as empresas só têm 8% de mulher
nos cargos de presidência anunciou e se
nós pensarmos nos conselhos de
administração a no topo mesmo da
carreira no topo hierárquico
nós vamos encontrar só quatro por cento
dos postos ocupados por mulheres
isso se nós descontarmos as herdeiras
claro é muito pouco
novas pesquisas em uma fresquinha que
acabou de sair
citou brasil entre o pior país em termos
de igualdade equiparação salarial em uma
lista de 43 países
uma pesquisa também dá é nesse ano da
consultoria que fala que nesse ritmo que
nós estamos com muito otimismo
nós vamos conseguir chegar ao falar dos
homens num prazo de 80 anos mas tem duas
mulheres que não querem esperar e aí
elas estão fundando as suas empresas
sendo empreendedoras e isso é ótimo
hoje no brasil existem quase 6 milhões
de mulheres empreendedores mas não é
ótimo não quando isso significa uma fuga
uma fuga sim porque dentro da empresa
ela olha para o lado e vê um homem que
faz a mesma coisa que ela faz
só que ganhando 30% mais que a média
dessa diferença salarial
ela vai para uma reunião e ela não é
ouvida
ou então ela fica de mau humor e ela é
chamada de mal amada para dizer o mínimo
e de repente aquela mulher super
qualificada porque hoje as mulheres têm
mais anos de estudo que os homens
ela pensa em engravidar ela fica
a vida e ela tem medo de ficar grávida
outro dia eu estava conversando com um
se ou de uma empresa de tecnologia e ele
me contou que uma das executivas mais
competentes dele entrou na sala da
presidência não falar dele
tremendo e com a voz baixa para falar
que estava grávida
aí ele disse pra mim que deu um abraço
nela e e perguntou puxa por que você tá
reagindo assim não precisa o que são
seis meses na vida de uma mulher
talentosa
hoje as brasileiras engravida uma massa
em duas vezes que quer um ano ao longo
de uma carreira inteira mas ele não
estava fazendo isso porque ele é
bonzinho não é porque ele entende dos
números e as novas pesquisas mostram que
mulheres na sua vida e na liderança das
empresas significam também maior retorno
financeiro às empresas lucram mais
empresas deixem as mulheres engravidarem
em paz
vocês estão perdendo talentos e quando
elas saem para empreender
às vezes elas têm a ilusão de que vai
ser diferente
hoje no brasil as mulheres ainda
entendem mais por necessidade e não por
oportunidade numa proporção aí de 60 a
40 por cento
e elas estão em setores que ainda não
produzem tanta riqueza e nem geram
tantos empregos
elas estão nas áreas de alimentação de
moda de beleza
elas não estão nas chamadas empresas de
alto impacto que são aquelas que crescem
a uma taxa de 20% ao ano
as chamadas status de tecnologia são
fundadas maciçamente pelos homens
mais de 90% delas hoje e é por isso que
elas não aparecem na capa das revistas
de negócios
são eles quem aparece mas essa situação
pode mudar já está mudando este mês de
novembro vai entrar na história das
mulheres brasileiras
nós assistimos aqui nessa avenida
paulista a marcha contra o cunha
nós assistimos a linda marcha das
margaridas
nós vimos nascer a campanha contra o meu
primeiro a fed e nesta semana uma nova
campanha mais recente com a hashtag do
meu amigo secreto
não é fantástico que as mulheres estejam
se manifestando eu acho fantástico
elas estão aprendendo que não devem e
não precisam ficar caladas
mas existem mais dois segredos que eu
quero contar pra vocês para que as
mulheres possam realmente mudar essa
situação
um deles se chama finanças
é preciso desmistificar de uma vez por
todas o aprendizado da matemática para
que uma mulher possa conduzir seu
próprio negócio ou ter sucesso dentro de
uma empresa ela precisa entender de
finanças existem razões históricas para
esse nosso problema e com dinheiro sei
se vocês sabem mas a pele 1962
a mulher não tinha jeito a cpf então ela
dependia do marido ou do pai para todos
os assuntos que forem relacionados a
dinheiro
mais gente mais de 50 anos já se
passaram e está na hora de mudar essa
situação
o outro segredo para mudar esse cenário
se chama networking é preciso encontrar
as pessoas mas pessoalmente mulheres
saiam das redes sociais vocês são a
rainha da feitos sociais
parabéns pra que estão aqui
aproveitem pra se conhecer o mundo dos
negócios acontece ao vivo e em cores e
pra mudar tudo isso também
a gente precisa encontrar uma
alternativa à chamada broder agem
todo mundo sabe que é isso né com os
homens protegem se apóiam e que tal se
nós enfrentarmos a sister agem em vamos
inventar a sister agem
vamos apoiar umas às outras
vamos parar de nos comparar pára de
comprar a roupa
o marido namorado filho papagaio
as meninas que vêm por aí a nova geração
elas precisam de novos modelos
elas precisam saber que não é preciso
esperar um príncipe encantado para ser
feliz
elas precisam saber que elas não
precisam nascer com a cara da gisele 20
entrou ser felizes
elas precisam descobrir que elas podem
ser cientistas que elas podem ser
presidentes que elas podem ser
astronautas que elas podem ser o que
elas quiserem ser que elas podem ser
donas do seu nariz
para as próximas gerações
o que eu espero é que elas descubram que
não existe limite para o talento humano
e quando a paula natália sair da cadeia
o que eu espero que ela encontre não é a
próxima garota da capa mas sim a próxima
sonhadora a próxima inovadora a próxima
empreendedora nas páginas das revistas
da internet e da vida
muito obrigado